le parti centriste également en lice
pour les européennes du mois de mai lui
dénient l'union des démocrates et la
dépendance son représentant local est
avec nous ce matin dans son caddie
bonjour philippe petit bonjour monsieur
le temps il petit avec une participation
sur la liste qui sera conduite par jean
christophe lagarde or quelle position
17e alors lui dénient très tôt philippe
qui avait fait savoir qu'il ne sera pas
de l'union avec la république en marche
ni le modem et d'autres partis
centristes choix assumé ce matin sans
regrets mais je crois que d'abord c'est
un choix démocratique puisque le 15
décembre à issy les moulineaux où il y
avait une convention un congrès
extraordinaire de l'ue dit et les
représentants que les présidents de
fédérations dont moi même ont pris leurs
responsabilités en pensant que d'une
part c'est une élection à la
proportionnelle
donc il est logique que les toutes les
tendances soient représentés il n'y a
pas besoin de prime à la majorité pour
dire qu'on doit exister majoritairement
et deuxièmement il ya un certain nombre
de carences que nous avons retrouvé en
tout cas chez la république en marche
qui font qu' il fallait un parenti pour
la faune fédérer les énergies européenne
on pose la question parce que le dernier
sondage de l'institut ifop par exemple
donne la liste renaissance art en tête
avec 23% d'intentions de vote en disque
lui dénier à bas perd légèrement
quelques points pour s'établir désormais
à 1 25% seulement
alors ce sont des sondages avant
l'officialisation de la campagne vous
avez vu que monsieur macron fait
campagne déjà depuis quatre mois sur le
grand débat ce qui veut dire que on a
polarisé entre marine le pen le
rassemblement national et la république
à manches
ça c'est une polarisation factice qui
est dû aux grands débats maintenant que
les choses vont rentrer et j'ai en fait
les téléspectateurs regardent et déjà le
premier débat le 4 avril donc c'est
judicieux france 2 ou qu' il puisse voir
lui-même qui est monsieur lagarde
quelles sont les propositions concrètes
et ce parti traditionnellement centriste
fait toujours des élus au parlement
européen
je le sais pas garde qu'il ya quand même
qu'il faudrait pas que cette élection
européenne ne soit une sorte de match au
tour de la présidentielle absolument ce
que je vous confirme et que par
conséquent il ya tout à fait la place
pour lui dis qui je pense sera
représenté au parlement européen
rappelons que le seuil de remboursement
de campagne de 3% et le seuil d'élection
des députés
est à 7% alors lui dire lui dei doit
faire entendre sa voix pour cette
élection là sur quelles valeurs fils et
petits d'abord la valeur européenne à
savoir que c'est la valeur de la paix
dans le monde
depuis nous sommes les heureux d'une
génération qui n'a pas connu de guerre
mondiale
c'est à dire que il faut vous dire qu'en
1945 se terminer la deuxième guerre
mondiale et contre la france et
l'allemagne a eu des guerres tout au
long des siècles du rop depuis les le
moyen âge et que par conséquent la
première valeur c'est la paix dans le
monde et la meilleure façon de faire la
paix c'est d'avoir des valeurs communes
qui je pense sont basés aux dépens sur
la chrétienté on peut en dire ce qu'on
veut mais a commandé des racines
chrétiennes de l'europe
et puis ensuite il ya une zone
économique qu'on a fait parce que le
meilleur chavire chose la deûle emmanuel
macron ce que vous dites la meilleure
chose pour pouvoir faire c'est du
commerce le problème de monsieur macron
si simplement que lui est allé dans la
théorie du ruissellement c'est à dire le
premier de cordée moi j'ai jamais parlé
ou en tout cas je n'ai pas entendu
monsieur lagarde parler du premier le
corner qui oui c'est le 7 a nié qu'il
est allé privilégier un certain nombre
de personnes donc dans cette union est
une tuerie comme une autre et notamment
dans le domaine de la finance
et il ne faut pas confondre le
libéralisme qui la libération de
l'individu
le capitalisme qui est logique de faire
des capitaux avec les les flux
financiers que vais aller que vers
lequel tend monsieur macron par
conséquent c'est pas tout à fait la même
europe ne sont pas disons que la sienne
est ultra libérale quelques en tout cas
telle qu'elle est conçue
intellectuellement avec ce premier de
cordée qui ruisselle alors que la nôtre
et participatif
ouais mais la participation le
participatif comme vous dites c'est là
la nuance sur laquelle il faudra compter
il n'y a pas que ça il ya une
proposition concrète quand monsieur
macro ont fait une lettre aux français
sur sa vision de l'europe c'est beaucoup
de théorie c'est à dire que c'était une
machine intellectuelle brillante sa
personne ne va le contester
et vous savez entre la brillance d'une
énorme que la brillance d'un banquier et
la réalisation de petits chefs
d'entreprise je pense que là dedans y'a
de quoi faire et que le délit est une
formation centriste concrètes exemple la
crise sociale sociétale économique que
traverse la france
exemple très simple les gaffes à vous
entendez comme monsieur le maire veut
taxer les choses et vous ne savez pas si
la rivalité 6 de scarlett comme google
facebook amazon enfin et microsoft aussi
d'ailleurs
et vous savez qu'il n'arrive pas à les
taxer parce qu'ils vont mettre leur
leurs ressources sur d'autres petits
états européens donc il faut avoir une
harmonisation fiscale et ce que nous
proposons nous en tout cas monsieur
lagarde et le staff nous avons réfléchi
sur le fait que comme ne l'avons pas
justement deux géants de l'informatique
et comme ils collectent nous donner à
chaque fois que vous allez sur facebook
eh bien il faudrait que les laits clear
de facebook c'est à dire les
martiniquais les européennes les
mondiaux touche parce qu'il donne et ils
permettent d'être humains et ils donnent
leurs données personnelles et à partir
de là il permet d'instrumentaliser
finalement la recherche sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui va aux
états unis donc par conséquent il
faudrait ne serait-ce qu soft en
pratique faire payer directement au
client une fois que les clients sont
payés mais l'état français pu récupérer
ou les taux européens pu récupérer de
l'argent sur ses clients au lieu d'aller
directement accès le chiffre d'affires
qui lui s'en va dans les paradis fiscaux
de voir voilà par exemple des images y
ont concrétisé du point positionnement
très claire de l'union européenne face à
aux mastodontes de l'internet qui sont
surtout basés aux états unis et puis la
chine de l'autre et pu lâcher notre côté
nous disons qu'à partir du moment où
tous plus jeune à l'époque quand j'ai
monté mon mouvement libéral martinique
et de l'époque dans les années
quatre-vingt douze c'est parce que le
il y avait eu le mur de berlin qui
s'était effondré et que justement il
fallait montrer que d'une part il
fallait de la liberté et d'autre part
qu'il fallait former l'europe puisque
nous étions dans la mondialisation et
donc ça n'a pas changé ma théorie n'a
pas changé depuis et elle est toujours
reconnu aujourd'hui officiellement
puisque nous sommes à l'ère de la
mondialisation
et vous avez vu ces concentrations qu'il
ya dedans trois mondes qui sont rois qui
ont des valeurs distinctes avaient
évolué à faire le consommateur européen
le consommateur martinique s y retrouve
ce stylo que j'ai en main coûte 7 fois
dix fois moins cher le bracelet de la
montre que j'ai moi aussi j'en commande
en chine etc
qu'est ce que l'union européenne
pourrait faire contre cela non mais je
mets au contraire c'est positif
attention c'est positif que vous payez
le payer moins cher c'est à dire que ça
veut dire que la mondialisation partir
du moment où les coups ont été diminués
c'est ça le justement l'économie
capitaliste qu'on décrit mais qui en
fait a permis d'abaisser les coûts donc
de donner du pouvoir d'achat
maintenant il faut que pour pouvoir le
problème c'est surtout le dumping social
c'est à dire que ce qui a été fait à bas
prix un coût social c'est à dire que ce
sont les ouvriers chinois qui sont qui
ne sont pas dans des conditions sociales
valable et est ce que nous ne pouvons
accepter ce en europe n'ont donc
effectivement il faut faire payer les
gaffes à pour que le citoyen s'y
retrouve et il faut harmoniser la
législation sociale européenne puisque
c'est à l'échelle de manche et européens
qu'on pourra trouver les conditions
sociales pour le travailleur les petits
quelle est votre vision du job du député
européen par rapport à notre réalité de
région ultrapériphérique alors moi je
suis de ceux qui parlent du comité des
régions qui est une chose consultative
mais qui permet de visualiser tous et de
visionner tous les traités qui passe par
le parlement qui sont ceux du conseil
européen de la commission européenne
viennent devant le comité des régions et
je suis tout à fait aussi peau euros
d'hommes ce que qui a été créé à
l'époque par des entrepreneurs menti ni
quand on peut citer ben ali faire du
giro manning pour faire du lobbying
auprès de bruxelles je considère que
c'est le lobbying auprès des
commissaires européens qui permet
qu'aujourd'hui la banane
ensuite puisque les textes reviennent au
parlement européen soit votée et que
c'est pas le nombre de parlementaires
antillais qui ont fait la banane par
contre que le lobbying sauf à ça j'ai
pas dit que ce débat ne s'est pas une
mauvaise chose mais on parlementaires
aux antilles mais il est souvent noyés
dans notre dans l'hémicycle s'est pas
c'est pas ça directement il ne fait
qu'accompagner du lobbying mais il faut
maintenant il faudrait plus de deux
représentants de nos pays sur les listes
et sur des listes soient convaincus de
cette nécessité de défendre nos régions
allonger les pressions par exemple
lorsque vous sur votre liste de l'udps
et ird et en 17e position que jean
christophe lagarde a donné un bon signal
moi je considère simplement que je viens
de vous dire c'est le comité des régions
ou bien sûrs ou d'hommes qui font un
travail de lobbying vis-à-vis de groupes
parlementaires et l'essentiel dans le
groupe parlementaire c'est que nous
ayons à ce niveau là déroulé comme suit
la garde mais 17e il ya peu de chances
que je sois élu député européen
compte tenu de ce que vous avez dit dans
les sondages nous verrons si ça remonte
mais je sais simplement que j'ai
quelqu'un s'il est élu député européen
que nous pouvons aller voir parce que de
la même façon qu'à l'assemblée nationale
je peux le voir en tant que président de
fédération unie je considère que c'est
un appareil politique important est que
la démocratie représentative vaut pour
la martinique comme pour la france merci
philippe petit de l'udinese martinique
la liste une france forte dans une robe
fédérer avec jean christophe lagarde
merci d'avoir été ce matin dans son
crédit bonne journée merci